part of the archaic revival is just
reaching toward the button called
Western epistemology science philosophy
religion and civilization and hitting
reset
uh you know that's fine they had 2 000
years to make their point and Deliver us
into Utopia or the arms of almighty God
or whatever the plan was and instead you
know what we've got is the crypts and
the Bloods and the rest of it and it's a
radical call to respect the Integrity of
your own intelligence
you should decide what makes sense you
based on your experience and your
self-examination should decide what
makes sense and if you need help
dead people are more trustworthy than
living people you know if you have to
have a guru
Plato
can't John the Divine you know but not
you know Swami Contempo or Guru garage
key no no it makes no sense at all we're
all in it together and and the other
thing is you know the mystery does not
require your belief
if the mystery is real
you can hold any damn opinion you please
about it and it will still be the
mystery so it's not about looking for
something to believe in nothing should
be believed in nothing is so
existentially compelling that it compels
belief it's much better to Simply uh you
know take a kind of an is that so
attitude toward what's going on and let
it all slide past don't cling the
universe is an endless
phantasmagoria phenomena and meaning is
an iridescence a fiction in the primate
mind the important thing is to affirm
experience
and the moment-to-moment quality of
immediate experience is what you will
look back on at the moment of death and
decide whether your life made sense or
not and these psychedelics
are you know volume controls on the
richness of felt and immediate
experience
they bring you into this devalued moment
called the now and they bring you into
the richness of this devalued piece of
real estate called my mind self and
Imagination and they show you that you
know you should never have traveled away
from this in order to become CEO or get
a Mercedes or buy a Rembrandt because if
you had just noticed where you were when
you started out you wouldn't have had to
go anywhere in the first place and this
is really the teaching of alchemy that
out of the moment out of the dross of
the existential moment can be distilled
affirmation
understanding appreciation
affirmation understanding appreciation
these are feeling toned complexes which
intersect in the body